expect that i thought he could build up
first he trades off one of the black
knights
maybe there's a knockout blow it feels
like there's a win look at white's queen
and bishop
they are lined up on the same diagonal
with their almost delivery checkmate
black's queen at the moment is parrying
those threats
stopping those threats okay magnus that
is so cool
so calm in a blitz game in a tie break
game just improves his last remaining
piece
that rook was the only piece not joining
the action he improves it eyeing up
the black queen indirectly magnus
shaking his head there maybe he thinks
he had something even better
this is still good but he needs to be
accurate now because his his advantage
is no longer
long term one there's a piece that's
dropped off
okay i didn't even spot that nakamura
just left his bishop
hanging oh wow he lost a bishop for free
he forgot to defend it it's a blunder
it's a blunder
and not even a complicated one magnus is
taking a free bishop
this game over nakamura he just resigns
wow and look at magnus he knows he got
well it was looking
amazing for him but he knows he got a
little bit lucky in the end there and
look at these two players right now
well david what is going through their
heads what what
kind of you see hikari that he kind of
made a gesture like he was like
what on earth was i thinking brain fart
right yeah exactly